[Music]
[Music]
this looks a good many tear it up your
bad no change this is the story of why I
switched jobs with my twin a long time
ago Lisa and I were conceived there was
a third but he never made it I came out
looking like Elvis Presley and Lisa well
blue and undernourished she made it
through and we entered the world
together me with an extra curiosity that
couldn't be scratched and Lisa a brain
that could absorb words faster than
twisted sailing from birth it was clear
that we were polar opposites so match I
was convinced for the most part of my
life that I was switched out at birth
but by DNA reports show that Lisa and I
were a very much part of the maize
famine we grew apart for opponents like
different sides of the earth apart she
became a lawyer a really badass one and
I became a foam Darrington I now I have
decided that it's time to make amends
with my sister and bridge the gap of
awkward silences at every family
function but before I do this we need to
understand it
I would have to live a day in her shoes
and she would have to live a day in mind
and like all siblings relationships
there is a prize up for steak the
ultimate prize ever the favorite child
award not supported by my parents but I
made it and I painted it gold which
means it's legette the favorite maze
child how ridiculous it's now half at
6:00 in the morning I usually only wake
up at 8:00 and it's my first time ever
wearing a suit it's time to talk through
the rules for today so you've written
your for Tiffany's for me to do and I've
written my fourth duties for you to do
create the rules here is the honor move
successful one which is a large line
which is either you can phone me or I
can burn you to one task hood for the
rest you can do anything
in order to achieve those tasks and the
winner of that becomes the favorite
child because there is so much of
mistake about new Tariq Oprah's almost
everywhere to share that they were
thank you
[Music]
being mafia dancin I'm Dan Richard list
of things to do I gave you support costs
that the Challenger creates a me but
where she could use her structured
mindset Lisa on the other hand at a
completely different idea and gave me
terrifying tasks that made no sense to
[Music]
Joslyn have absolutely no okay I need to
clear my head I need to do something
somewhat creative yeah is a
comprehensive review of what it's like
to be inside of an open
steps lots of stairs stamps that could
verify things
[Music]
files nuts a nut supplies and spin -
order in 1200 300
cameras every things weren't looking too
hot for me at the law firm the back of
my studio Lisa seemed to be sty this new
app called Adobe watch and so you're
really great way for people just edit
video so we get to talk about that
lieutenant over some talking points good
see I'm on skype exactly a docket sense
talking points
[Music]
I can
thank you so much Scott
I was mr. don't feature me
[Music]
screw that I'm gonna leave this one I'm
gonna pass on that I know for a fact
that lease is not gonna finish all of
her tasks okay you ready to go yep dan
has exciting find dissipation to talk to
you about but so long here's a few
points about Adobe rush this
how does dan memorize it all and more
you take massage brush I smashed the
first all-in-one video editing app for
all of your devices they were chatting
via really easy onboard onboarding in
New Jersey onboarding intuitive easy
onboarding sure to create flexibility
well these are certificates these speeds
through her tasks I said struggling to
understand pretty much anything let's
take a quick look at the scoreboard Lisa
with two and myself with Sierra house
man Dan right listen she phoned me one
of the clans here and you do it before
the conveyancing perspective
[Music]
you see this long pause of awkward
silence well this is around the time we
both attorney and client figured out I
wasn't a real lawyer
I felt like a complete - needed to step
out for something I keep this thing's
live music Dan I'm gonna use my last
night now I want to break it
well hold on hold on the price on that
batch of crazy push dog
yo this was the one task I thought she
wouldn't be able to complete what are
you honest thoughts about today about
this job you know what the strange thing
about this job is first as my job is
right now it's hot and I can't stop
thinking about the serve and in my job I
would just go surfing
but now I've got a sitter and ya know
it's a horrible feeling to know I know
the whole time there's so much structure
the sermon they say feels like what I do
is so so small in the big scheme of
things that like I never really
understood how things worked on his side
how can he seem so disorganized yet he
is so super successful have I let myself
believe that I am like this person that
knows all the [ __ ] or am I just naive
and making phones
one thing from the list that's all I
need
I'm going to be seriously disappointed
if I can't figure this out I'm the
cruise to the beach
meanwhile at my studio Lisa seems to be
sailing through her final task but also
me who is editing right now starting to
realize that I was extremely lenient
with my tasks but then again that could
also just be the Saudis within me I then
lit my hair back took off my tie and
took a romantic solo walk on the beach
for the sole purpose of dramatic
amplification yo I'm tired staked
experience that because I know I made
the right decision and what I do for
sure well for me let's go with Lisa
cleaning up four to zero it was time for
me to hand over the truth the moment has
come the moment that burns me hurts my
heart makes me feel deeply shut even
compete one task therefore you have to
be
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with me and for something that was very
eye-opening for me and something to
experience and know that the corporate
kind of world just isn't for me but I
also respect the corporate world let's
just quickly talk about Adobe Rush which
is super dope because it works across
mobile and desktop so you can edit on
the move and in this day and age that's
true power and the true power of rush is
that it is available wherever you are
and the ability to work on the curb
create and share online content anyway
make something with rush and then share
it with me with the hashtag made with
Rush and hashtag Dan mace and then I'll
be featuring and sharing some of my
favorites over the next couple of weeks
other than that don't forget your
awesome brew and I'll see you
is that a cricket like a real cricket
I'll see you when I see you
[Music]